okay let's get started so for some
logistics the poster session is tomorrow
1:30 p.m.
print your posters well ahead of time
hopefully you've are either already
printed it or you're going to print it
very soon
your final project report is due Monday
the 16th at midnight you're very welcome
to submit it earlier and this is a hard
deadline like no late days for this
because grades are due very shortly
after this deadline so try to get it
done early and then of course this is
the last lecture and I'll leave some
time for course evaluations at the end
so you can fill those out and we're
looking forward to the feedback that you
had throughout the course especially
since this is the first time that we're
offering the course ok so let's get to
the main topic so I think today is
actually in my mind one of the most
interesting and exciting lectures
because we're going to talk about one of
the things that don't work very well and
some of the things that we might do to
resolve these challenges and really the
first part of the lecture and most of
the lecture will be covering some of the
research that we've been doing very
recently to try to mitigate some of the
challenges and meta learning and
multitask learning and the second part
we'll get into some more open and
unsolved challenges in these topics
beyond all of the challenges that we've
covered in the rest of the course cool
so what does it work very well the first
thing that I'd like to talk about today
is where do we construct tasks for meta
learning and for multitask learning in
general we we saw reasonable ways to
construct a state for example for future
division classification but in much more
realistic situations it may not be clear
how your how how you might go about
getting the set of structured data from
the data sets that you however the data
sets that you have a means to collect
and in particular we'll talk about some
of the televisions that come up when you
try to construct tasks such as
memorization problems such as how to use
time series data without task boundaries
and how do how to actually have
algorithms that can come
with the tasks themselves from
unstructured data sources and then
beyond the problem of tasks I'm gonna
talk a little bit about how we might go
about running multi task RL and meta RL
across very distinct task families so
before we were saying like different
variations on a task like running
forward or running backward or running
at different velocities or reaching to
different points in space and can we
think about actually running multi task
our element RL across qualitatively
distinct tasks I will talk about
challenges such as how do we go about
actually specifying the task to the to
the agent what set of distinct tasks do
we train on and what are some of the
challenges that arise when we actually
try to do this and then lastly we'll
talk about open challenges okay
so first let's talk about how to
construct tasks for meta learning and to
briefly review you're talking about
earlier in this course few shot image
classification and the way that we kind
of the kind of problem that we wanted to
solve was something like this where you
wanted to be able to learn from data set
to classified new examples and the way
that you would construct your tasks or
your distribution of tasks would be
something like this this is what you did
in your homework where you separated the
data in two sets of classes and you
randomly assign labels to each of these
images and then basically train the
network set to the operating the data on
the Left it could make classifications
on the right now one of the things that
you did here is you essentially shuffle
the labels you randomly selected a label
category for each of these five images
and that was kind of randomly permuted
for every single task now one of the
questions I'd like to ask you is what
would happen if we didn't shuffle the
labels and in particular what if we
always kept the category corresponding
to mushroom as the second class label
and what if we always kept the category
corresponding to a singer as the fourth
category and piano as the fifth category
what would the middle what would what
would the meta learning algorithm do
what
what at work would it would everything
be the same would it be different does
the question make sense right so this is
actually something that's a little bit
different so in your homework one of the
things that you do one of the things
that you found that many people found to
work better is that you always like oh
the think of course behind the class one
was always printed first I think course
behind the class two was always for that
second etc what I'm talking about here
is actually the assignment of semantic
class labels the semantic classes to
class labels and so in your homework you
would always you'd randomly sample class
and assign that to a class label and
then once you assign the class labels
you had passed those class labels in in
sequence but what if for example this
state the semantics class always
correspond to the same class label like
birds were always one mushrooms Row is
to that particular breed of dog was
always number three singer was always
number four yeah yeah can you elaborate
on that a little bit it will be looking
for the class label as information
yes that's that's like very close so
what what would it let's see what would
the would it like would it be if you
give it a new task corresponding to the
same classes that it saw in the training
set would it be able to perform well if
it sees the same task as one of the ones
that saw before but just different
images would it be able to perform well
yeah and then if you change the change
the order of the class label would it be
able to do well yeah yeah so basically
it can just memorize the ordering of the
labels and say okay bird is always the
first label if I see a bird I can just
output one right and then mushroom is
always a second like one you always just
output two and so then if it ever sees a
mushroom or a singer or something and
always just know what to do it doesn't
actually have to pay attention to the
training dataset to figure out the
ordering right and so it could actually
one that can learn to ignore the
training data for each task because it
can just output the label and two of us
give it a new class and it doesn't know
what the ID if it's given a new semantic
category it doesn't know kind of the
label corresponding to that class that
it can't it can't figure out what what
class level that corresponds to so let's
look at another example that might make
it a little bit more clear so say we
want to learn a post predictor and what
we do is we reason we want to predict
the orientation of an object and we want
to be able to adapt to a new object that
we've never seen before so say we have
some top training
and we're given like four examples per
object labeled with the orientation of
that object and our goal is given four
images we want to be able to predict new
new orientations of that same exact
object right now to solve this task one
of the things that the learner can do is
just remember what the canonical
orientation of each object in the
training set is and then use that
canonical orientation to output the pose
of that object absolutely it can
actually learn to ignore the training
data and just kind of memorize the
canonical orientation of the object and
output at the actual orientation is this
a problem well this is fine for the
objects in the training dataset and if
it sees a new couch that has the same
canonical orientation it's fine right
when is it bad so this is the problem
when you see new objects right so if
you're for example you're given a new
class of object that you haven't seen
before you don't know the canonical pose
of that object then because your meta
learner just memorize the canonical
poses of all that all of the training
objects and learn to ignore the data on
the left it can it can't generalize to
this new setting because it doesn't know
how to use the data in order to figure
out the canonical orientation so this is
kind of bad we were given an unseen
object with an unseen canonical
orientation does this make sense
any questions about why this would fail
all right so then the question is like
if this is a problem like basically we
want to be able to kind of train our
post predictor and it can just memorize
the post of all the objects of all the
trading objects get perfect training
error and then generalize poorly when it
sees new objects because it doesn't know
the canonical orientation of that object
I'll refer to this is the memorization
problem because it can memorize it
aspect of the training dataset in a way
that doesn't allow it
to generalize to the test set then the
question is can we do anything about
this so let's try to actually formally
think about this problem so in the
homeworks that you did for a few shot
image classification where you're
changing the labels it was true that a
single function couldn't solve all of
the tasks and the reason for that is
because you had changed the kind of
class label corresponding to bird across
different examples so you can't you're
thinking I it would be that like I you
can't have a single function that output
a class label of two for bird or a class
label of one for bird and this is due to
label is shopping or hiding information
from the ADA like an interview and for
similar example you might hide the
position of the object that you want to
reach and it has to learn that through
reinforcement now if the tasks are what
are called non mutually exclusive that
means that a single function actually
can solve all the tasks and if a single
function kinzhal solve all the tasks and
there's actually multiple solutions to
the meta learning problem and the way
that you can see this is if you view
meta learning as learning this function
that takes as input training data and
the input X what it could do is just
choose to ignore that training data it's
usually ignore the train date and just
learn the function that takes as input
the image or takes as input the input
and makes a prediction based on that so
one solution is just memorize the
canonical pose if the objects ignore the
training data and output the pose of the
training objects with our function and
another solution would be to not carry
any information about the canonical pose
in your meta parameters data and acquire
that information from the training data
and then if you see these two solutions
then you can actually see an entire
spectrum of solutions based
how information flows based on how much
information about the canonical pose of
the object you're carrying in theta
versus carrying in versus acquiring from
the training data okay does this make
sense any questions yeah so there is
actually and so this is um you can
actually measure these sorts of
quantities through mutual information
and other information theoretic
quantities like information theory like
entropy for example some of the
quantities basically that Sergei
mentioned in his lecture one kind of
formal definition that you can think of
of when this is a problem is when
basically the mutual the mutual
information between your prediction and
your training data given your input is
equal to zero and what this means is
that maybe this is also given the
parameters of your function theta what
this means is that the training data
isn't affecting your prediction in any
way and and serve their mutual
information is zero you're basically
picture is only dependent on theta and X
all right so this is this kind of
characterizes when when you might just
memorize this sort of quantity and now
one of the things that we could do about
this if we take this view is that we
could potentially solve this problem by
trying to control the information flow
in a certain way by basically trying to
control whether or not the information
comes from X whether or not the
information is stored in theta or
whether or not it comes from the
training data okay
so one of the things that we can do is
what we'll call meta regularization
which is to minimize the meta training
loss which is our our performance on the
Mediterranean set but also the
information that's stored in theta so
for example if we don't want it to
memorize and store information about the
canonical pose and theta then we can
minimize the Mediterranean also minimize
the amount of information in theta by
using an information bottleneck by
essentially constraining a distribution
over theta which will be parametrized by
theta mu and theta Sigma to be close to
this prior distribution that doesn't
that carries very little information now
one of the things that's really
important is to actually include this
first term because if you only include
the second term which is to minimize the
information and theta then you wouldn't
have any information in theta and you
would do terribly on your meta training
tasks and that's where that beta term
comes in is that you need a balance
these two terms effectively and what
this what this actually does is for for
larger beta this is going to place
precedents on using information in the
trained is that overusing information
and your meta parameters okay and then
you can combine this with your favorite
meta learning algorithm at optimization
based algorithm or also like a blackbox
adaptation approach
yeah so the way that we do this is you
can for like an optimization based
algorithm like mammal what we do is we
add noise to the to our weight vector
that is has magnitude of theta Sigma
basically and that's that that's the
variance of the noise and you learn both
the mean and the variance such that you
do well on the train data set and such
that you try to stay close to this prior
you can't achieve both of these
objectives and so if you only use the
second objective then you just be adding
you just basically have random noise as
parameters as theta and it so it's that
first term that also encourages you to
do well on the training dataset does
that answer your question yeah so that's
a good point so in this in in the case
like mammal theta is both the meta
parameters and also kind of the update
rule like the way that you actually go
about learning from the training dataset
the update rule I guess is both from
theta and also the gradient stop and so
disentangling that's those two is
difficult to do an approach like mammal
in a black box approach and so in that
case we find that it just works best to
do it on on all of the parameters in a
black box approach where you have
separate pathways from the training data
set and X and then you might have some
some intermediate variable which we'll
call Z and then you make a prediction we
find that it makes sense to put the
regularization only on this pathway and
not on the pathway from here and that
kind of allows you to do what you're
suggesting which is to only regularize
and minimize the content from from the
input and not the pathway from the
training data but something that's a
little bit more difficult to do in
optimization based like looks like a
mammal based approach
right so you could also try to minimize
performance when you mouse the data yeah
so this is approach that does something
somewhat like that called task agnostic
meta learning where you try to what they
try to do is they say that
so in mammal you have theta prime equals
theta minus alpha grad something like
this and what they trying to do is they
say that F theta should output a
distribution that has maximum entropy I
think it's nice that what they're doing
is maybe a little bit different from
what you're so well I'm not sure what
they say is basically this should have
maximum entropy which corresponds to
like minimum performance basically
should output a uniform distribution
over the labels in practice one of the
things that I think an approach like
that can do is is sort of cheat and say
and pretend to like not have any
information about the the inputs but
when you then take a gradients epoch and
real it can kind of just flip a switch
such that it it knows they can then like
it'll pretend that doesn't know anything
but then once you flip that switch it's
accessible to the to the function yeah
and so if you do something like Omni lot
without label shuffling like I was
describing before but we called
non-mutually exclusive Omni lot mammal
does pretty terribly on this in
comparison to what happens when you
shuffle the labels this this approach
that I just mentioned where they try to
maximize the entropy of the output also
does quite poorly when you try to
generalize to new settings because it's
like basically secretly hiding the fact
that it's memorizing things whereas if
you regular lies the information and
theta like I mentioned before you can do
substantially better okay and then on my
quiz on the post prediction tasks the if
you compare mammal to the meta
regularize variant and also conditional
neural processes which is a black box
approach to the meta better regularized
version of that you can see significant
improvements by
incorporating this objective for this
regularizer and this isn't just just as
simple as standard regularization so one
of the things that we tried is adding
the sort of standard regularization on
all of the parameters of conditional
neural processes and we find that if you
do it on all the parameters in this
fairly naive way you also do fairly
poorly whereas if you just simply
regularize the pathway that that that
you care about then you're able to
achieve good performance okay any more
questions on that before I move on okay
so the reason why I think this is
important is that there are many
settings where we can't necessarily
shuffle the labels and make the tasks
not mutually exclusive and so I think
there's there's work represents a step
towards making my learning algorithms
more generally applicable to those kinds
of settings next what if we have data
that doesn't have task boundaries so in
that setting we we had half boundaries
but the we had these memorization
problems but we had these we didn't know
kind of that what the underlying task
structure was instead what if we simply
have like a time series of data and we
want to be able to medal earn from that
time series the data in a way that
allows us to make predictions about new
tasks very quickly and so some examples
of this might be if we want to predict
energy demand or if we want to predict
the dynamics of a robot or of a car we
want to predict transportation usage
across time if you want to make some
money predict the stock market video
analytics of reinforcement learning
agent all of these situations are
examples where you have unsegmented time
series of data but there is significant
temporal structure so there's structure
that that affects that the nature of
that data for example energy demand is
going to be different if the weather is
in different situation if the weather is
very hot versus very cold the dynamics
of a car gonna be vary if you're on like
a grass terrain versus a very slow for a
very paved terrain transportation usage
is going to vary
based off of different sports events or
whatever so there's significant temporal
structure that that governs the these
processes and we should be able to
actually recognize that temporal
structure in those time series and latch
on to it in order to make effective
predictions and so what we're gonna try
to do is learn to segment the time
series into tasks and then medal learn
across those tasks so then the key
question is how do we go about
segmenting the data so in this work
which was led by James Harrison and
Apoorva Sharma
one thing they looked into as an
approach called Bayesian online change
point detection which assumes that you
have some discrete task switches
according to some probability so you
might have data that looks like this
where you have data according to some
process and then there's a discrete
switch and then you see data from
another distribution and then you
maintain a belief over the duration of
your current task as well as a posterior
distribution for your model for each of
those durations and then what you can do
so for example the the duration would be
something like this so you're kind of
it's being incremented by 1 until
there's a disgrace that task which in
which case the run link will be back to
zero and then what you can do with this
is when you have your belief over your
toss distribution you can recursively
update that belief using the performance
of your models so if your perform if
your models performing very well that
means that you're probably in the same
segment whereas if your model is
performing worse that's it's more likely
that you have switched to a different
task okay so that's kind of a very brief
and crude overview of Bayesian online
change point detection one of the things
that's neat about it is that these
recursive updates are completely
differentiable and so what that means is
that you can actually back prop through
the update of your belief over the test
duration to update your to kind of to
train your model or more Dometic your
model so you can simultaneously learn
these change points as well as the prior
across these change points using
meta-learning
and so the name that that James and a
part of I came out for this is mocha or
meta learning with online changepoint
analysis and what they found is that are
the problem citing that they're
considering is first during
Mediterranean you're given an unscented
time series of data of offline data you
want to be able to simultaneously learn
how to recognize change points and to
learn priors to for future learning
within those segments of data and then
it met a test time you're given a
streaming source of online data and you
want to simultaneously learn from that
data and make predictions from that data
it's typical to the typical online
learning problem setting okay so kind of
an example of how it works is they first
looked at a sinusoid regression setting
where there's discrete shifts in this
underlying sinusoid curve and what this
is showing is on the bottom is the
belief over the the current run length
of the task segment and what the top is
showing is that the green is showing the
curves from the previous previous time
steps and the red is showing well the
green and the red are showing the points
from the current the previous time steps
and the red ones are the ones from the
current task as labeled by an Oracle and
so what you can see is that I can very
rapidly recognize when there are change
points based on its belief over the
function and also very quickly adapt to
that so even with just a couple points
it can figure out what the sinusoid is
corresponding to that correspond to that
data point okay and then they also
developed a very image net that is also
kind of streaming data where you don't
know the task boundaries during
méditerranée and in comparison to just
training on all the tasks which which
get is the kind of the black line on the
bottom this is able to do significantly
better so the x-axis here is showing the
hazard rate or how frequently the task
is switching basically the probability
that the task will switch and the y-axis
is showing accuracy and each of the
approaches in red are basically using a
sliding window to basically méditerranée
across all of the data points within a
fixed window size so if I actually tried
to predict where these chains points are
it's able to do
Gately better than just using this naive
sliding-window approach okay cool so
this means that we can use data without
just kind of a time series of data
without any task boundaries now can we
take this one step further and just
assume that we have not even time series
data with temporal structure but just an
unlabeled data set of images for example
can the algorithm come up with its own
tasks in a way that prepares it for
future downstream tasks so let's first
look at the the unsupervised case we
have images and then we'll look at the
reinforcement learning case so let's say
that we have unlabeled images typically
we assume that we have we can track
tasks with with label data so the way
that we're going to try to approach this
problem is we're gonna try to construct
the tasks construct these kinds of tasks
but with unlabeled data and so to do
that we need to in some ways kind of
group the data into different images and
then also label the images within those
groupings so what we'll do is to group
the data we will we can't group the data
in pixel space we can't like run like
k-means and pixel space that wouldn't
work very well and so what we'll do is
we'll first run unsupervised learning to
get a low dimensional embedding space
and that will allow us to take some
images and bed them into some low
dimensional space and then we'll propose
tasks by clustering with in this low
dimensional in space so for example one
set of clusters might look like this
another set of clusters might look like
this so we can cluster the data multiple
times in order to create different
groupings of the data and then to get a
task we can sample these different
groupings and treat each of those
groupings is a different class label so
say we wanted to create a two-way
classification task we could sample two
classes maybe the red class and the blue
class sample those two images sample two
images from those two groupings treat
that as the training data set sample two
more images and treat that as the test
set and this would allow you to create a
one-shot two-way classification task and
you can repeat this process and for
example sample the green cluster and the
purple cluster to create more
to create more tasks and so on okay and
so this gives us a set of tasks and then
once we have that we can simply run our
favorite meta learning algorithm be a
black box approach to optimization based
approach or a nonparametric approach
okay
and then the result of this process is
if you do something like mammal is a
representation that's particularly
well-suited for few shot learning was
our question so in this case the total
number of tasks corresponds to the total
number of clusters choose the number of
ways so if you want to create five-way
classification tasks and you have a
thousand clusters and you could create a
thousand trees five tasks
yeah
so in this case the like each cluster
may not correspond to an actual semantic
class label so for example we've found
clusters that correspond to pairs of
objects or around objects for example
and in general kind of the idea behind
this algorithm is that they don't
actually need to necessarily correspond
to exactly class labels what's important
is that they correspond to structured
structured aspects of the visual data
such that the meta learner can figure
out you directly learn to recognize that
structure very quickly from only a few
examples and make predictions and so for
example you could imagine basically
practicing for a few shot learning by
practicing with these other sorts of
concepts like round and pairs of objects
in a way that allows you to then a test
time when you're giving us very small
data set be able to adapt very quickly
to that data set so the Downs after you
do this after you perform metal learning
you'll be given the downstream task a
very small data set for that downstream
task and your goal is to quickly learn
that task and that data will actually
correspond to like ground truth ground
truth semantic labels ok so there's a
few different design decisions in this
approach for example we need shoes and
unsupervised learning algorithm there
are a few options two of the
frontrunners that we used were baigan or
or deep cluster then we proposed house
by by clustering and as with most
machine learning papers these days you
need to come up with a fun acronym for
your method so we called it clustering
to automatically construct tasks friends
supervised meta learning or cactus and
then we run our run different meta
learning algorithms on it and if you're
curious what the combination of a cactus
and a mammal looks like you get
something like this and let's see how it
does so we've looked at mini imagenet
and if you give many image that like
full labels with mammal this was kind of
a control it gets around 62 percent
success this is with like a fully
labeled méditerranée data set and then
all the other methods will not use any
of the labels in the
trained ears that they just get to see
the images they don't know anything
about how those images correspond to
classes and then kind of the key
question is how does this sort of
approach the sort of unsupervised meta
learning approach compared to just using
the representation of these approaches
directly so for example we can take the
baigan representation that's learned and
do kinis neighbors in that
representation with the downstream data
and if we do that we get something
around 31% test meta test accuracy we
can also do a logistic regression on top
of that representation if we do that we
get around 34 percent success we also
tried using a neural network on top of
that representation and then using
dropout to regularize it and that
actually did a little bit worse than
using logistic regression you could also
imagine approach where you try to match
the clusters if you try to basically
want to use the clustering that you do
here you could try to match the clusters
with that representation to the data in
your test task training set if you do
that you get around also around 29
percent success in comparison if you do
if you do mammal on top of the clustered
baigan representation you get something
like 51 percent accuracy so by
explicitly training it for the ability
to quickly adapt to tasks it's able to
learn a prior that can effectively
transfer to downstream a few shot
learning tasks and if you combine it
with d+ where you do a little bit better
than that as well
and one of the things that was
interesting was that this result didn't
just hold from any image net it also
held for four different embedding
methods for different unsupervised
learning approaches across four
different datasets Omniglot Sulabh a
mini image net and amnesty to medal
learning methods mammal and prototypical
networks although prone that's
underperformed in a couple of cases and
it also worked well with test tasks that
have larger data sets so for example if
you're in the 50 shot case rather than
in the five shot case these this
approach could also perform well yeah
yeah one thing that's interesting here
is can you then kind of after you read
metal learning like close the loop and
use that to refine the tasks we for
something we we I admit we added per
typical that works is a somewhat
last-minute addition to this paper with
mammal we found that if we reuse the
mammal representation it actually wasn't
good for proposing tasks which suggested
to us that one basically these sorts of
embeds are very good for proposing tasks
and the metal and embeddings are very
good for basically adapting to test
tasks and they these two sorts of
purposes aren't necessarily like useful
for the same sorts of things for
something like proto nuts I that's not
an experiment that we ran but it could
be pretty interesting to try conceivably
it does seem like you should be able to
improve with the sort of iterative
iterative toss proposal okay so now
about what doubt what about unsupervised
meta reinforcement learning so this is a
paper that or kind of an approach that
sir gave very briefly touched on in his
guest lecture where I'll try to go on in
a little bit more depth than that and
what the general recipe will look like
is very similar to the previous approach
which is we be given an environment we
want to be able to propose tasks in an
unsupervised way and then run meta
reinforcement learning on those tasks
and then the result of that will be a
reinforcement learning algorithm or a
reinforcement learning procedure that is
particularly tuned for a given
environment and then for that
environment if you're given a new reward
function from a human you should be able
to very quickly maximize that reward
function with a small amount of
experience so then the key question is
how do you go about proposing tasks one
very naive approach that you could
imagine doing but maybe still does
something reasonable is to use random
task proposals so in particular what you
can do is you could just randomly
initialize neural networks that
basically classify whether or not a
state corresponds to
given tasks and so in particular what
we'll do is we'll have some
discriminator that outputs a load it's
over a discrete random variable and if
the probability of that correspond to
task one is higher than the reward
function for that task will also be high
and likewise for for other tasks so it's
basically gonna try to classify which of
a discrete set of tasks each state
belongs to and in this case the users
could be a randomly initialized neural
network and one of these you could
imagine this doing is essentially just
randomly partitioning the state space
into different regions such that one one
of these partitions corresponds to one
task another partition corresponds to
another task all right
and one other thing that's really
important to note here is this is random
functions over the state space not over
the policy space and so in the reason
why this is important is that if there
are random functions over the policy
space then you'd kind of have an
exponential search problem over the
policy that kind of visits a set of
states whereas if it's a random reward
functions over state space I instead
just have a polynomial search problem
okay
so this is kind of the first naive thing
that we could do is there something that
we can do that's a bit better than this
and in particular one thing that we can
imagine doing is trying to actually make
a set of tasks that are more diverse
from one another and in particular the
way that we can do this is try to make
tasks that are discriminable from each
other skills that look different from
one another the way that you can go
about doing this is actually very
similar to the approach cactus that I
mentioned before which is to try to
actually cluster skills into more
discrete parts of your policy space and
now we can't in the reinforcements are
you setting when you actually generate
the tasks I generate the kind of skills
and so what we'll do is we'll use an
approach called diversity is all you
need or Dian is an approach that Sergei
covered in his guest lecture where you
have an agent or a policy that takes as
input a discrete skills e it produces
actions and you have a discriminator
that takes as input
a sequence or a state and it tries to
predict which skill was passed into the
policy and then what you have is you
have a cooperative game where the policy
tries to visit which states are
discriminated bowl by the discriminator
and the discriminator tries to predict
the skill from the state so the
objective of both of these is to
maximize the accuracy of the
discriminator and then once you once you
have this discriminator then you can
have the reward function for
unsupervised meta learning to simply be
the likelihood of one of those skills
given in the state so here are some
examples of the acquired skills that it
acquires through this approach and so
basically what this what this approaches
corresponds to is learning these skills
with this sort of discriminability
metric or objective and then runs meta
learning across these skills with these
which each with each of these skills as
the meta training tasks ok so does this
work the short answer is I yes so if you
run if you run this algorithm and then
give it some downstream tasks specified
by a human for example and navigating to
different 2d positions or running in
different directions or running to
certain points in space the kind of the
the result of the meta learning
algorithm is something that can much
more quickly solve these downstream test
tasks then learning from scratch and one
of the things that's particularly
interesting here is that even training
with the random tasks which is shown in
blue is able to do significantly better
than training from scratch in two of the
three cases and also the if you use the
diversity driven skills shown in green
it's able to learn much very quickly in
all three cases yeah
yeah I think that's a great question I'd
love to see more work on manipulation
and in particular I think that
exploration of manipulation is very
challenging because in in locomotion
like exploration is just like visiting
different parts of the state space very
clearly
whereas in something like manipulation
if you wanted many people objects like
just waving your hands around randomly
isn't actually a very good exploration
strategy even though it is like
exploring of a very large part of the
state space for your arms and the things
that do actually matter are objects and
doing interesting things with the
objects so I think that these kinds of
approaches would struggle if like these
kinds of exploration approaches if you
apply them to manipulation settings may
not do as well and we may need like
basically different tactics for
exploration in order to do that one of
the things that I think is exciting
about metal learning in the context of
exploration is it seems like you should
be able to learn an exploration strategy
that's particularly tuned to a domain so
for example if in bokeh motion versus a
navigation versus a manipulation it's
probably the different exploration
strategies are actually better for
different domains how one is very object
driven another is very kind of region
driven and it seems like you should be
able to instead of trying to have hand
code and algorithm that is good at all
these different domains you should
instead be able to learn an exploration
approach for that's pretty clearly
tailored towards each of these domains
okay so I guess for me though one of the
interesting things here was that team
like relatively simple mechanisms for
proposing tasks worked surprisingly well
but it's possible that these sorts of
things may not work well in in a
manipulation setting the other barrier I
think for manipulation settings is that
there aren't a lot of good environments
for our manipulation that are kind of
very well grounded in the field and very
well widely used okay so some takeaways
from this part of the lecture is that we
can learn priors for future on occasion
using a variety of data sources
including Nam usually exclusive tasks
including unsegmented time series data
and using unlabeled data and unlabeled
experience and the way that we could do
this is through a meta regularization
with end-to-end change point detection
and using clustering of your skills or
if your data points and in general I
think that all these approaches should
make it significantly easier to deploy
meta learning algorithms but at the same
time I don't think that these are
necessarily the final approaches for
each of these problems all of this work
is extremely recent and I think that
there's there's really a lot more work
to be done to make it easy to boy meta
learning algorithms ok so now I won't
talk about what does it take to actually
run these algorithms on very
qualitatively distinct skills and the
motivation here is that in in a lot of
the kind of goal condition reinforcement
learning multi task reinforcement
learning and meta reinforcement learning
we see that the different tasks just
correspond to different variations of
the same skill rather than completely
distinct skills and so if you think
about whether or not things like mammal
and Perl have actually accomplished our
goal of making policy adaptation very
fast I think that they sort of
accomplished this goal to some degree
and that we can kind of very quickly
adapt to new situations but they haven't
shown the ability to adapt to entirely
new tasks and one of the challenges in
doing this is that if we want to adapt
to entirely new tasks we also know that
we need the kind of the task
distributions at Mediterranean met a
test time to be the same and so what
this means is that we need a very broad
distribution of tasks for meta training
so it seems like there's kind of two
steps to things that we need to do here
first is the ability to just meta train
over at least like two task families
rather than just within a single toss
family and the second step is to meta
training across a very diverse set of
tasks that allows for generalization to
entirely new tasks so first I'd like to
talk about the first point which is can
we perform better training across
multiple task families and in particular
what we'll consider is the settings
right here where we consider a space of
multiple manipulation tasks including
things like grasping objects pressing
buttons sliding objects across the table
and stocking two objects so I think it's
pretty fair to say that these four
things are fairly distinct from one
another and much more distinct from one
another than the tasks distributions
that we saw earlier in this course and
then our goal will be to learn in this
case our people will not be to
generalize to an entirely new task it
will simply just to be just to
generalize within this broader task
distribution and in particular to learn
a new variation of why these tasks
families with a small number of trials
and sparse rewards for that task okay
now one problem that comes up when you
start to think about this problem is
that if you have sparse forwards if you
just have like if the robot gets one
when it accomplishes the task of zero
otherwise then the robots gonna have to
explore every possible task to figure
out which one is the one that is
supposed to be doing so for example if
you have like a robot right here you
want it to be able to quickly learn a
task you just want to be able give it
one when it did something good and zero
otherwise then we basically have to poke
all the objects in the scene to figure
out which which is the thing that you it
you want it to accomplish and it seems a
bit silly because we're just kind of
hiding we're purposely hiding
information from the robot by not
telling it what tasks we want to do so
the way that we're going to try to
overcome this is in particular try to
give it an indication of what the task
is and and then also given that
indication haven't figure out how to
perform the task and in particular we'll
see if we could learn from one
demonstration which we'll use to convey
that what the task is and a few trials
which will be used to figure out how to
solve that task okay and so kind of
concretely what this might look like is
there were I
it'll watch one demonstration as shown
on the left it will then try the task
itself in a new situation so in this
case it'll try to push the the tea cup
over to the right in this case this this
wasn't quite the correct thing to do and
so it will learn from that that a reward
of zero from that situation to figure
out that what it should have done in
that situation is to push the cup
towards the tea cup so in this case
we're also introducing some amount of
ambiguity in the new situation such as
it has to figure out if it to push the
object
the left towards the right or the object
on the right towards the left okay the
how can we train for this in a scalable
way if we want to learn from
demonstrations and trials the way that
we'll do this is we'll collect a few
demonstrations for many different tasks
we need this in order to learn from from
demonstrations well then first train a
one-shot imitation learning policy you
to be able to imitate the to imitate the
the demonstration for each task this is
something that we can do completely
offline from the day that we collected
which is nice
well then collect trials for each task
by running this one-shot imitation
learning policy in the environment and
we'll do this in a very in a batch off
policy setting where we just collect a
large batch of data once and then we're
done collecting data and this is pretty
easy to do and or easier to do in
real-world settings so they don't have
to be iterative lis constantly
collecting data and then lastly we'll
train a policy that learns how to retry
the task using an imitation learning
objective so what we'll do is we'll give
will train kind of a meta learning
algorithm that gets both the
demonstration and one of the trials that
it collected in step three and train it
such that the resulting policy is able
to perform the task in a way that
closely matches the demonstration in
that situation okay so basically D train
is going to correspond to a demo and one
or a couple trials and then the outer
objective will correspond to a new
demonstration of that task okay
so in our experiments one of the things
we want to look at is this approach
which we call watch try learn in the
sense that it's watching a demonstration
trying the task and then of learning to
do the task we also want to compare this
to meta reinforcement learning that only
uses trial data and it isn't giving an
indication of the task do demonstrations
and this is going to be very hard for
the reasons that I mentioned before
because you have to poke all the objects
and then also compared to meta imitation
learning that only uses demonstrations
and is only allowed isn't allowed to
kind of retry the task and you situation
and then lastly we'll also compare two
approach that doesn't use anybody what
that just behavior clones all the
demonstrations so quantitatively what we
can see is that across the board the
approach that uses a trial and a
demonstration and a trial is its first
able to learn decently well across the
forecast families it also significantly
outperforms only using demonstrations
which is shown an orange and also it
also is if the outperforms using only
trials in this case using only trials
performed so poorly that we didn't
actually plot it on this graph it was
basically getting zero percent
performance because it was just a very
challenging optimization problem okay
and then we can look at some qualitative
examples so this is similar to some of
the qualitative examples we showed
previously so here's the demonstration
then it gets one trial where it has to
figure out how solve the task so it
tried to in this case it tried to push
the object on the left towards the right
and that wasn't the correct thing and so
it figured out that need to push the
object on the right towards the left and
likewise for something like a grasping
task in this case it's given the
demonstration which is to grasp why the
objects in this case that it wasn't able
to grasp on the first try and then it
figures out using that experience and
it's experiencing in the dynamics to
figure out how to successfully grasp the
cup
and then one last comparison we did is
we took the behavior cloning approach
and fine-tuned that with reinforcement
learning on one of the test tasks and we
found that that required 900 trials of
reinforcement learning in order to match
the performance of what wtl is able to
get it is just a single trial so this is
kind of emphasizing the efficiency that
meta learning can give you okay and one
side note on memorization is that one of
the things that we specifically did in
this problem setting was to make it such
that the demonstration only partially
specified the task and didn't kind of
completely specify the task and one of
the things that will happen is if the
demonstration fully specifies the task
then it will basically just resolve to
one-shot imitation learning and will
learn to ignore the trials during
meta-learning this is basically sort of
a variant on the memorization problem
that we mentioned before and this might
be this is like resolving the one tone
imitation learning is fine if you're
good at the meta test tasks so like if
you're given a demonstration of a task
and you can like solve the task very
well from that demonstration then you
don't need trials and like life is good
but if you're given a demonstration and
then you can't quite solve the task you
fail at the task then this is where
memorization is a problem because once
you fail at the task that means that you
don't have any mechanism to quickly
adapt from trials and then you may have
to run reinf like fine-tuning with
reinforcement learning in order to
actually learn a policy for the task
okay so essentially this is just a
variant on the memorization problem
where it's ignoring part of the training
data and in principle some of the
algorithms that we mentioned previously
that actually regularize information
flow could help solve this problem okay
cool so we talked about how we could
train across task families now how do we
go about generalizing to entirely new
tasks right to do that we need a broad
distribution of tasks but we also need
that broad distribution of tasks to be
fairly dense we can't just take four
tasks from that task family and expect
generalization to an entirely new task
so we need a broad and not sparse
distribution of tasks then the question
comes is like the question that comes up
is where do you actually get that
distribution of tasks there's a few
options for this from kind of the
reinforcement learning literature so
there's things like opening item and
like the Atari learning environment both
of these aren't very satisfying options
for meta learning because there isn't
necessarily very clear underlying
structure that you could leverage to
quickly learn new tasks from this
distribution there's also a suite of
tests called surreal or Robo suite and
this suite of tasks has a considerably
more structure but it only has six I
think around six tasks and so that also
isn't something that we could use for
metal learning to quickly learn new
tasks what we really want is
many qualitatively distinct tasks so
maybe 50 or more tasks and we want each
of these tasks to have reward functions
and success metrics for meta
reinforcement learning we also if we
want to be able to do meta learning
across this we want to be able to study
transfer as we want all the tasks
themselves to be individually solvable
and lastly we want a unified state space
in the unified auction space and so
motivated by this just does it errata we
created a benchmark that we called meta
world that I think many of you probably
are familiar with it was mentioned on on
Piazza
that has each of these traits so it has
50 distinct tasks shaped reward
functions for each of the tasks and also
a unified state space in the unified
action space such that we can hope hope
to actually see some generalization to
entirely new tasks shown on the right
okay so the key question is how do
current algorithms actually work when
you run them on this set of tasks so
kind of the TLDR is that there's some
signs of life but there's significant
room for improvement and in particular
if you look at the performance of medal
learning algorithms like mammal are l
squared and pearl they get meta tasks
performance that's in the 20s or low 30s
um so this is a bit perhaps
disappointing but also exciting because
it means that there's a lot of room for
improvement for future algorithms so
then the question is well why why are
they performing so poorly and if you dig
into the details it turns out that the
reason why they're performing so poorly
isn't because they're generalizing
poorly but because they're actually
having trouble doing well on the
Mediterranean distribution so they're
performing poorly even on the 45 meta
training tasks and so then you're okay
the cam natural thing to think as well
can we just do multi task RL on the 45
tasks and if you then run multi task are
all algorithms on these 45 tasks they
don't need to generalize to entirely new
tasks they just need to be able to kind
of do well on the training tasks these
these algorithms also struggle to do
well on
the 45 or in this case on the 50 tasks
in the benchmark okay so what's the
problem here we we developed all these
algorithms it seems like there is
considerable structure among these tasks
right so why the poor results so you
might think well maybe it's an
exploration challenge maybe it's having
trouble exploring in a way that allows
it to figure out how to solve these
tasks but all the tasks are individually
solvable with reinforcement learning
algorithms so it isn't an exploration
problem we know that if you try to solve
the toss individually you can everything
works just fine then you might as well
maybe it's a data scarcity problem like
maybe we just aren't giving enough data
to perform these tasks well but all of
them are in the in these comparisons all
the methods were given plenty of data
plenty of samples within their budget
they were also given plenty of model
capacity so that isn't the the challenge
and kind of the confusing thing here is
that it turns out that training models
independently from one another actually
performs significantly better than
training a single model across all the
tasks so kind of going back to some of
the things that we talked about the very
beginning of the course it seems like
the algorithms are having trouble kind
of sharing information and sharing
weights okay so our conclusion from this
was that it must be an optimization
challenge so it's not a model capacity
it's not a data promised on exploration
challenge it seems like it must be an
optimization chalasis that's preventing
these algorithms from solving the
training tasks so I'll let me go about
solving this optimization challenge we
had a couple hypotheses for what the
underlying optimization problem might be
the first hypothesis is that it seems
like maybe gradients from different
tasks are conflicting with one another
and this they seem like a reasonable
hypothesis because if they weren't
conflicting with each other then it
seems like the optimization process
would be fine and so if there is
conflict then we would see negative
inner product between different
gradients I would see gradients that are
kind of pointing in opposite directions
and our second hypothesis which is
important is that when they do conflict
they caused more damage than expected
and the reason why this hypothesis is
important is that if the if the
gradients are pointing in opposite
directions just averaging the gradients
should be the right thing to do and
that's what standard multitask
reinforcement learning would do is just
to simply average the two gradients and
then the one that it's higher in
magnitude is the one that will kind of
dominate more right so it seems like
averaging isn't the right thing to do
and we need to do something that tries
to mitigate some of the damage that is
being caused by these gradients pointing
in opposite directions and in particular
our hypothesis here currently is that
the damage is being caused by high
curvature so for example imagine this is
1d example where you have a
one-dimensional parameter vector and a
loss function that's shown on the y-axis
if you have high positive curvature then
you have maybe a function that looks
somewhat like this if you take one point
on that's curved maybe this is where
you're currently at and you can also
measure the gradient of this function
now
this is the the loss function
corresponding to one of your tasks and
maybe it's the case that another task
has a larger gradient and it wants to
move right on right in the right
direction on the x axis so then what
will happen is that if you want to move
right according to this gradient if you
move right and take a certain step size
you would end up here but in reality you
don't actually end up there you end up
up here and so even though your gradient
was at a relatively low magnitude and
said that if you go right your loss
function wouldn't get that much worse in
reality because of the positive
curvature you actually ended up in a
much worse place in terms of your loss
function than your gradient suggestin
yeah um so principle yeah a smaller
learning rate could certainly fix that
with the caveat that then learning would
be a bit slower yeah
mm oh yeah so for the first question
right now we're just looking at
multitasking we're not looking at mammal
at all because we just want to solve the
training tasks and so yeah so that's
although at the same time where we think
the hypothesis is about curvature but
the solution won't end up involving a
curvature or won't end up involving any
second order information and so that
should in theory play nice thing with
mammal for your what was your second
question again yeah yeah so in this case
the gradient for an algorithm like si si
would be the gradient of your Q function
of your critic and the gradient of your
actor and we would be talking about the
gradients of both of them it may be that
one of them suffers from this challenge
more so than the other but in practice
when we look at this we're looking at
both of them yeah okay oh and then with
regard to the smaller step sizes again I
blew this up so that we can see it for
visualization purposes and practice even
with smaller step sizes you would also
have this problem if you have very high
curvature so in practice you would never
take a step size probably that large but
yeah okay cool so given these two
hypotheses our approach the problem was
when taking a gradient step for one task
try to avoid making the other task force
and this is motivated by the fact that
maybe if we make the other task worse it
will get a lot worse or more worse than
we expected and so in particularly the
way that we can do this is very simple
our algorithm will simply be that if two
gradients could inflict with one another
essentially if they if they have
negative inner product then we'll
project each of the gradients onto the
normal plane
the other gradient and so particular
will project the gradient of one of the
tasks on to the normal planet the other
and will project the the gradient of the
red tasks on to the normal plant of the
blue tasks and as a result when you
project this this gradient this is
essentially in some way solving a
constrained optimization problem that's
trying to change the gradient such that
it doesn't actually affect the lost
function of the other toss doesn't
actually get any worse according to your
gradient it may actually get worse if
there's certain curvature but it should
get less worse according to your
gradient than if you were to take the
original one and if they don't conflict
then don't do anything you can just
leave them alone and they should
interact in a positive way yeah yeah so
if you only do one of these it is
asymmetric and so what we do is we do
both of them to make it symmetric so we
called this projecting conflicting
ingredients or PC grad because that's
what we're doing we're projecting the
conflicting gradients okay so how does
this work
so if you run multi task RL on Metta
world on both 10 tasks and Metta World
and 50 tasks and Metta world what we see
is that this approach shown in purple is
able to learn seen infinitely faster and
significantly better that if you were to
train independent networks and also
significantly better and seen a feeling
faster than if you try to do weight
sharing without this without this sort
of optimization trick to make the
landscape or to make the optimization
work work in a more clean way okay so
this helps a lot on on reinforcement
learning and it's hopefully a step
towards actually making meta learning
algorithms work well on this benchmark
but that's not a step that we've done
yet and then another question is well
this helps for RL but does it help for
supervised learning so we also ran it on
multitask supervised learning benchmarks
that we've seen in the literature and we
could also see that in comparison to
other approaches it is able to
outperform a number of previous
approaches it also combines well with
previous architectural solutions to to
molted house starting so rowdy networks
for example is one architectural
solution to multitask RL and if you
combine that approach with the
optimization solution of PC grad it can
perform significantly better than all of
the approaches and then we also compared
this on the nyu v2 data set which has
three tasks predicting segmentation
predicting depth and predicting service
normals and we're also able to see a
significant improvement from from using
PC grad here as well so kind of the
takeaway here is that it also helps
multitask supervised learning compared
to a number of different multitask
architectures that you could use okay
and then lastly one question you might
ask is why does it work so well and here
we want to kind of confirm some of the
intuitions that I mentioned earlier and
in particular one of the things we tried
is that when you project onto the the
normal plane you're changing both the
magnitude of the gradient and the
direction of the gradient and so what we
try doing is an ablation where we
changed only the magnitude or changed
only the direction of the gradient and
left the other component of the gradient
unchanged compared to just averaging
across the gradients and what we found
here is that the first both components
were important but the most important
component was changing the direction of
the gradient and not the magnitude of
the gradient and to us this provides
some evidence of the kind of the effect
of the kind of the intuition that I
described previously which is where we
don't want to affect the gradient of the
other task by changing the direction of
the gradient okay so some takeaways
first is scaling to broadcast
distributions is hard and it can't be
taken for granted from the algorithms
that we have currently and to do to kind
of try to do this we can try to convey
task informations beyond the reward
function for example using a
demonstration we could try to train on
very broad and dense toss distributions
such as meta world although there this
is kind of an initial approach towards a
good benchmark and there definitely is
lots of room for improvement there and
also trying to avoid conflicting
gradients by projecting gradients when
they could avoid
okay so that's the last part about kind
of very recent research now I want to
talk about some of the more open
challenges and multitask learning and
meta learning and it's worth mentioning
that I think that we've covered a large
number of challenges and downsides of
approaches throughout this course and so
I'm going to try to just just discuss
some of the things that we haven't
previously covered in the course yet so
the first class of challenges in my mind
is just trying to address the
fundamental assumptions that we make
when we set up the problem of multitask
learning or the problem of meta meta
learning and the first assumption is
this assumption that the meta training
in the meta testing tasks distribution
must be the same and this is I think
really important because there are gonna
be many situations where we have out of
distribution tasks or very long tail
toss distributions so we may have a
distribution that looks like this where
we have a lot of data in kind of the
head of the distribution and small
amounts of data in a wide range of
situations such as different objects
encounter different interactions with
people different words heard different
driving situations etc and in principle
we know how to diffuse shot learning so
we should be able to adapt to small
amounts of data in the tail but the
catch is that these few tasks on the
right are from a different distribution
than the ones where most of our data is
and so in order to solve this problem we
need to be thinking about settings or
algorithms that can handle assumptions
where the Mediterranean task
distribution and the meta testing tasks
distribution aren't the same and and
some hints I think towards this problem
might come from the domain adaptation
literature or the robustness literature
where we're trying to be do well on
basically on data points that are kind
of from the tails of our distribution or
from a different distribution as I can
tell it is multi-modality so a lot of
kind of a lot of the motivation from my
learning is to leverage previous
experience and the previous experience
came in the form of a set of tasks or
kind of a set of data sets but in
practice in the real world we may have
much more rich sources of previous
experiences ranging from image data to
touch feedback to language to social
cues
and so I think it's important to think
about how we might learn priors across
multiple data by LEDs that can be
compiled into some single prior about
the world or some kind of single source
of common sense knowledge about the
world and some of the challenges that
come up here is that you have varying
dimensionalities of these of these of
these modalities different units of
these modalities and they also carry
different forms in different actually
complementary forms of information and
some hints at this problem might come
from the multimodal learning literature
for example but I think that this is
really an unsolved or really unexplored
area and then the last question is when
should we actually use multitask
learning or meta learning when will it
help when wouldn't will give us benefits
and this is in many ways a problem with
algorithm selection or model selection
okay so that's talking about the problem
assumptions another challenge that we've
started to get at a little bit but not
really in a satisfying way is is better
benchmarks and in particularly I think
we need kind of in this class you'd
explore you explored Omniglot we also
talked a lot about mini image debt and
we talked about meta world today I think
that ultimately we need benchmarks that
both reflect breadth of kind of the
types of distributions that we want to
cover so that we can generalize broadly
as well as realism we want them to
reflect the kinds of real world problems
that we want to solve and so we have
some steps towards good benchmarks that
we saw in this course such as meta data
set today we saw a meta world there's
also a new benchmark called the visual
task adaptation benchmark and there's
also the task task economy dataset by is
mirror at all and I think that these are
really kind of important steps towards
better benchmarks for actually studying
our algorithms but ultimately we need
benchmarks that can really reflect the
real world problems I can have the
appropriate level of difficulty for
where we're at right now and are also
very easy to use
and I think that many of these days says
don't capture kind of all of these
different properties and the reason why
benchmarks are important is that without
benchmarks we can't necessarily make any
progress on the algorithm side of things
make progress on solving the problems
okay and then lastly is simply just
improving core algorithms and this is
something that we talked a lot about in
the course so I'll just talk about it
briefly here things like handling
computation and memory requirements and
making large-scale bi-level optimization
actually practical to run on on the
computers that we have today trying to
develop more of a theoretical
understanding of the performance of
these algorithms so we talked a little
bit about theoretical measures of
expressive power and different
assumptions that are our algorithms make
I think that there's a lot of work to be
done to under better understand what
these approaches are doing and lastly
one thing that we didn't cover that much
in this course is looking at problems
look at multi test problems where you
want to perform tasks in sequence and
this sort of sequential decision making
problem I think is particularly
challenging because one task the
starting distribution of one task will
depend on where the policy for the
previous task takes you and actually
along in a number of these directions
there's been a number of final projects
that have tried to look at some of these
challenges so in addition to these
there's also kind of the challenges that
you hopefully discovered in your
homework and final projects great and so
I also like to talk just very briefly
about the bigger picture and and some of
the motivation for this course so one of
things we talked about the very
beginning is kind of how if you look at
a lot of existing machine learning
systems in many ways they're kind of
very specialized towards particular
applications they can perform one very
narrow thing and one kind of narrow
environment and hopefully if we care
about building machines that can go into
real-world environments and they can
look more like the they can exhibit more
of the generality and flexibility that
humans have and so in this course I I
think we covered some of the steps
towards these sort of generalist machine
learning systems such as systems that
can learn multiple tasks that can
leverage previous experience when
learning new knowledge they can learn
general-purpose models of the world they
can prepare for tasks before you know
what they are such as exploration can
perform tasks in secret
and can learn continuously in like
lifelong learning settings now what's
missing towards systems there that are
kind of generalizable I think that now
you're equipped with the tools of this
task in it this is something that you
are well prepared to figure out great so
a couple more reminders the poster
session is tomorrow the file project
report please submit it before the 16th
and please fill out your course
evaluations we'd love to hear any
feedback that you have either through
course evaluations or over email or in
person thank you
[Applause]